I think there was a terrible misstep
with
atheism and what it did was it unhooked
a set of
protections some of which really weren't
no longer necessary many of which were
still essential but for reasons that
were not literally explained in the
documents in question and I know because
for a while I was pretty close to the
only evolutionary biologist trying to
bridge this Gap and speaking to
religious people and saying look my
colleagues are telling you you're sick
with a mind virus I know that's not
right um doesn't mean that what you
think took place literally happened and
we have to have that conversation what
if what you believe is important but not
literal right getting there from an
evolutionary perspective if we could
have done that earlier and not
temporarily flirted with the idea that
you know simple atheism was somehow a
sophisticated way of navigating through
life mhm then
maybe um we could
have maybe those people who had
long-standing Traditions that contained
wisdom uh that might have prevented this
would have had more power when it
mattered all right now everyone watching
this knows that I'm not going to let you
just black pill us the whole time and I
know that that's not your intention and
actually your life's work is to to not
do that at all but just to give the
Devil's Due and do as much of what you
just discussed as we can so would you
say it's something like we've had you
know 250 plus years of the Enlightenment
that got us past much of the tribal
stuff and now we're we're just at the
end of it does does this feel inevitable
where we're at at the moment especially
if you look at what's happened you know
since October 7th where we're now seeing
a new version of tribalism burst forth
does it seem like the obvious end of
Enlightenment liberalism ISM
unfortunately something that guys like
you and I tried to defend very hard
before it was cool I guess right and
while there was still more opportunity
it's now later unfortunately in that uh
in that history but I think it was not
inevitable but in order to avoid it we
needed to recognize what we had and not
delude ourselves about how complete the
job had been in other words recognizing
that we had effectively
discovered the the broad structure that
we needed to live by and had never fully
achieved it right obviously the founders
of the American experiment
simultaneously understood that nobody
needed to be given advantage over
anybody else or it was essential that
they not have advantage over anybody
else at the same time they preserved
slavery so it was never perfect it was
at best a prototype but we had to
recognize what that prototype implied
about what kind of world we could have
and then we needed to defend it with
everything we had we needed to defend it
and we needed to I don't even want to
say complete it because that that imp
implies that you're going to get there
there's no there there you're going to
approach it right you're going to get to
a place where the gap between the system
you have and the system that you're
trying that you're shooting for is so
small it's it's not worth messing
anything up over what do you think the
closest we've ever got to that was like
to I always say on the show now if we
could just reverse it to 1995 were
probably probably pretty good well yes
and no I think
1995 is not a bad estimate of the
closest we got right and just as a proxy
for it the degree to which one's race
for lack of a better term mattered was
probably at a low E at that point yeah
it didn't matter at the level of zero it
mattered right and certain races
mattered more than others but everybody
understood all of the decent people
understood that it was desirable to have
a world in which everybody had access to
the market nobody was barred because of
where they came from and we have now
lost touch with that obviously we've
we've embraced the idea that nothing
matters more and of course that is going
to produce uh a Revival of all of the
ancient rivalries and a bunch of new
ones and it just doesn't look survivable
and what's more I think if you could
just simply
teleport everybody for a couple of days
into the future that they are toying
with delivering us all too they would
recognize instantly that the loss that
they were that they were contemplating
was just Unthinkable what if you could
teleport the other way so what if we
could teleport to 1995 assuming it's a
roughly it's not the exact year but
ballparking that things were better what
would you tell the people of 1995 you're
supposed to do in the face of this
because that's what I keep coming back
to a bunch of us were screaming about
this clearly that wasn't enough yep so
what would you tell the people of 30
years ago how you going to fix this that
is an extremely difficult thought
problem and in fact I fear that the
answer is short of by the way I'm from
the future I know you're not going to
believe that but if you can get over
that one thing if I can establish that
one thing for you then I've got a
message about what's about to happen and
what you have to do to prevent it and
why it matters right that you could do
but if there's no way to convey hey
actually I've seen where this goes and
it's not good right so you need Marty
telling doc that he fell off the toilet
to figure out the flux capacitor but
short of that we're kind of screwed I
think so because I know you know
actually it's funny Heather and I have a
little uh just sort of private thought
experiment you know because we knew each
other in high school I'm often saying to
her don't you wish that we could uh just
tell our high school elves about the
present and what would they say right
and the answer is it's not plausible
yeah the idea that we would get here is
is unimaginable and I think people I
don't want to say would rightly reject
the message because it would sound too
Preposterous but of course it would I
mean we're fighting about whether men
can become women whether you know
pedophilia is a sexual orientation that
you can do nothing about and we should
be tolerant of whether 2 plus 2 really
equals four I mean literally there is
nothing left that we can agree on
nothing so okay so short of being able
to prove that you were from the future
is there anything in retrospect that we
could have done again that's the thing
that I still seem to be hung up on is
this all inevitable that the system was
going to collapse the algorithms were
going to Grapple a hold of us the the uh
the ren Seekers as you're talking about
in the elite like all of it was
inevitably going to get us to this
civilizational moment
well there are a couple things that go
into it which were probably necessary
ingredients and so maybe if you could
prevent one of them you'd you'd be
somewh better and the two that come to
mind most
directly
um I think there was a terrible misstep
with
atheism and what it did was it unhooked
a set of
protections some of which really weren't
no longer necessary many of which were
still essential but for reasons that
were not literally explained in the
documents in question and I know because
for a while I was pretty close to the
only evolutionary biologist trying to
bridge this Gap and speaking to
religious people and saying look my
colleagues are telling you you're sick
with a mind virus I know that's not
right um doesn't mean that what you
think took place literally happened and
we we have to have that conversation
what if what you believe is important
but not literal right getting there from
an evolutionary perspective if we could
have done that earlier and not
temporarily flirted with the idea that
you know simple atheism was somehow a
sophisticated way of navigating through
life then
maybe um we could
have maybe those people who had
long-standing Traditions that contained
wisdom uh that might have prevented to
this would have had more power when it
mattered I really think um that's so you
must be pleased then in that there
doesn't seem to be much of an atheist
movement left in America I don't know if
pleased is the right word but it does
you know I think that the Sam Harris
Jordan Peterson debates sort of put an
end to that movement in America as they
should have but I'm not thrilled with
what I'm seeing replace it and I think
there's a you know let's put it this way
if we take your question about what
could we have said to the people of 1995
to get them to save us from the world of
um the the coming Calamity that is going
to happen if we just simply embrace the
religious doctrines philosophies and
values of the past and hope that we can
now ride out the storm that's when we
could stop now by having a conversation
that says look it was wrong to dispense
with these compendiums of wisdom that
we've been handed in all of these
Traditions but those compendiums of
wisdom were built by natural selection
in an environment we no longer live in
and so we are we are stuck in a terrible
problem which
is you can't embrace the solutions of
the past to get out of the problems of
the present and you can't abandon the
solutions of the past because they're
outdated because you'll end up
abandoning all sorts of stuff that
matters in ways you don't know about so
that is I I don't want to candy coat it
yeah there's no simple solution to that
that doesn't involve um repeatedly
injuring ourselves as a civilization as
we discover which fraction of those
Traditions is still relevant which
fraction has become uh toxic and
inappropriate what it should be replaced
with that's a very long-term puzzle that
you can only solve if you're careful
about it there's no there's solution you
can deliver in the present and say
Here's the subset of those Traditions
that's still relevant here's the part
that needs to be replaced here's what it
needs to be replaced with that's an
evolutionary process that's going to do
it if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop screaming check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell